woher kommen sie woher kommen sie ich
komme aus deutschland
ich komme aus deutschland sie ist
deutsche
sie ist deutsche sind sie amerikaner
sind sie amerikaner
ich komme aus münster aber seit ein paar
monaten lebe ich in berlin
aus welchem land kommst du aus welchem
land kommst du mein mann hat eine
doppelte staatsbürgerschaft
eine polnische und eine deutsche
mein mann hat eine doppelte
staatsbürgerschaft
eine polnische und eine deutsche ich
lebe in berlin eine sehr internationale
stadt
ich lebe in berlin eine sehr
internationale stadt in berlin
fühle ich mich zu hause in berlin fühle
ich mich zu hause
ich liebe berlin